Okay. Time to draw the square. But this time,
using the computer. So, I created a new Python
file and called it mindstorms.py. You could've called it
something else. And then, inside it, I created a
function called draw_square, which, for now, is empty. Now,
I know there is this module in Python called
turtle. This is the actual thing that moves around
and draws stuff on the computer. By the way,
I encourage you to find out why this thing
is called turtle and not a dog, or a cat.
One way to start to draw is by saying, turtle.Turtle.
Now, this syntax is a little weird and we will
understand it by the end of this video, but
it suffices to say that this is how we grab
out turtle. I will call it brad. Now, the first
thing we want to do is move brad forward. And we
can use the forward function for that. This function takes in
a number, which is the distance we want to move forward.
Now, I just want to run this code, and see if it's
even working. But, you know what, the one thing we forgot,
is that we still don't have a screen on which this
turtle, aka brad, is going to move around. In other words,
we need the red carpet equivalent in our program. I know
that is done by adding a window screen, and this window is
going to have a red background, and I want to be able to close
this window any time I click on it. Now, let's save and run this program.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
All right. It seems that we have a window with a red background. And a turtle
named brad, which has moved 100 steps forward. Okay, so I am back at the code,
and now I'm going to finish making the square. So, after brad has moved 100
steps forward, I want to turn it right, and I want to do so by 90 degrees. So, I
can say, brad.right 90, and because I want to
do these two steps right here, four times to draw a square, I'll just
copy paste them a few times. So, I'm going to copy these two lines
and I'm going to paste them. Second time,
third time, fourth time Let me save and run,
alright, it seems like we have our first square.